well efforts are underway to form a new
government here in germany it's taken
them a few weeks to agree on a draft
document to start the talks but now the
negotiations to form a coalition
government are officially underway
previously the social democrats the
greens and the liberals agreed on
important cornerstones such as no tax
increase and
increase in the minimum wage but the
three parties have yet to agree on some
highly contentious points on climate for
example the greens are set to win their
case with a coal exit brought forward
from 2038 to 2030 but with no clear road
map as to how to achieve that goal
in terms of security although the draft
paper mentions a modernization from the
german army the social democrats and the
greens haven't committed to fulfilling
germany's uh
goals within nato of spending two
percent of its budget on defense uh last
but not least the liberals and their
leader christian
have already expressed a strong interest
in getting the finance ministry that's
something that was not welcome very much
by the greens or
the spd
well for more we're joined now by
ricardo long she's a deputy chairwoman
of the greens and a member of the german
parliament thanks for being with us mr
long a three-way coalition
yeah
yeah
a three-way coalition that's what you're
looking at right now that's going to
demand compromises all around
what policy goals has your party already
had to sacrifice going into these
negotiations and and what are you not
willing to give up going forward
well i think first of all when we come
together with three parties that are
ideologically very separate and very far
apart i think what was really
interesting in the last weeks was that
we were bill able to get into a one
direction to build a reform like to
formulate a basis for
agreeing on the paris agreement before
getting investing into future um areas
and also for getting children out of
poverty the exploratory
paper we have here is something where
you can see the decisions were made
decisions being made is good for
politics but it also means that you have
to give and you get to take so we have
great successes with index
paper for example the coal exit but what
was rather hard for us was for example
giving up the temple limit on our and on
our streets
you're talking about the speed limit
that uh you would like to see introduced
uh in order to reduce co2 emissions yeah
the other the other coalition partners
didn't go along with that what do you
see as the biggest points of contention
moving forward in these negotiations
well for us as the green party was
always clear that every government we
will enter into has to foreign on the
paris paris agreement and therefore on
reducing co2 and i think now this we
have emma built a ground for this for
example with the coal exit but now we
have to get concrete on it when it comes
to how we change agriculture when we
comes to how we change mobility and i
think these are going to be one of the
big areas we are going to talk about
within the coalition talks now now you
personally have put a lot of emphasis on
social equality on gender parity uh do
you think that your would-be coalition
partners are willing to prioritize those
goals
well what we agreed on an exploratory
paper is that we want a guaranteed child
allowance to get children out of poverty
and this is a priority that we agreed on
within the paper and i think this is a
big step for many many families for many
single parents and for many children
within this country and this will be our
priority within the coalition talks and
also within the next four years because
i think in a rich country no child
should grow up in poverty and we will
also push forward for more social
successes within the coalition talks now
but i think that especially when it
comes to gender equality we can agree on
in these three parties even though our
instruments may differ that the equality
between all genders and between men and
women is a question of freedom is a
question of self-determination and
there's simply no discrimination based
on gender and i think this is a good
like
starting point now to get into the
instruments
thank you very much for talking with us
that was ricardo long from germany's
green party
thank you have a good day
you